rire osawa samosa Polamalu
équation précédente wa boku GA cela donne un citoyen
de Seto galiyaron SE
aki maeda quasi-militaire geste de Solano
lamas Thiele Felicio méchant
contrôle bas égalité absolue Roger je
veux mundo y león contact avec la macchina
et elle a besoin d'un permis est LOV  sur Mon
gateau moment et tantine ouais
les tampons de clé mimosa incluent la
table ANOVA
er noms votre
porte-voix de chatte a sauté est la séquence dont Tom et
moi parlons depuis plusieurs
années Tom sera le premier acteur à faire
un saut de halo sur le
halo de la caméra  sauter ce saut militaire ouvert à haute altitude à basse altitude
à 25 000 pieds en ouvrant une
goulotte en dessous de 2 000 pieds et se faufiler dans
le pays étranger sans être
détecté c'est l'idée de Halo
il y a beaucoup de risques à aller à
25 000 pieds le public peut dire quand
quelque chose a été trompé  semble
important de tout faire pour de vrai
il y a des dangers d'hypoxie et les virages
vous commencent à perdre la tête mais vous ne vous en rendez pas
compte nous avons dû développer un sp  ecial
casque qui est à la fois un accessoire et un
dispositif de sauvetage la première phase de
la séquence hello consistait à construire une
machine à vent suffisamment grande pour que
nous puissions répéter, nous avons donc construit l'une
des plus grandes souffleries au monde, personne ne
pensait que cela le ferait  il faut plus d'une centaine de
sauts pour obtenir la scène dont nous avions besoin aux
EAU s'ils n'étaient pas intervenus, nous
n'aurions pas pu accomplir la
séquence que nous avons faite cinq sauts par
jour sur le Twin Otter dans l'après-midi,
nous ferons trois c  -17 sauts et c'est un
défi
nous tournons une séquence de nuit la
lumière doit être parfaite
nous voulons prendre une photo par jour vous
devez filmer le plus près possible du coucher du soleil donc
nous avons exactement trois minutes
chaque jour pour prendre la photo  vous ne pouvez pas simplement
monter dans l'avion et partir vous devez
passer 20 minutes au sol à respirer de
l'oxygène pur pour ne pas attraper le
mal de décompression l'avion doit
monter à 25 000 pieds bien que l'
éclairage passe du blanc au rouge vous êtes
parler de Tom jump  sortir d'un
avion voyage à 165 milles à l'heure
tomber à 200 milles à l'heure et Kista se
positionne de manière à atterrir
exactement à trois pieds de la caméra
avec 20 000 pieds sous lui le risque d'
une collision en vol nous étions vraiment
inquiets  il y a toujours un compte à
rebours et le tournage d'un film mais ce n'est
généralement pas la terre qui vole vers
vous merci gentil whoa j'ai hâte qu'un
public voie ça je n'arrive toujours pas à
croire que nous l'avons eu
[Musique]
Miss Univers même  tombez qui cinéma
ne
vous déplace pas